ومن مصر الى عنوان ثاني كان مسيطر معانا
في 20 22 رغم انه امنياتنا في 20 21 كانت
غير كده في 20 21 العنف ضد المراه
والجرائم والاعتداءات عليها كانت من
ملفاتنا الرئيسيه على مدار السنه وتمنينا
انه يكون 20 22 مختلف لكن للاسف الكابوس
مكمل ومشاكله هيخلص
واحنا في اجتماعنا التحريري اليومي كفريق
عمل تفاعلكم اصابتنا حاله صدمه واكتئاب من
الكم الهاء من العناوين عن الجرائم اللي
بتصير بالجمله همم
والقاسم المشترك بينها انه الضحيه هي انثى
لونها جميل علي حيدر طفله يمنيه عمرها عشر
سنوات ضحيه جديده من ضحايا زواج القاصرات
في اليمن البشعه اللي راحت ضحيتها طالبه
في جامعه المنصوره اسمها نيره اشرف بعد ما
قلت لها زميل لها امام رصيف الجامعه
الجديد اليوم مقطع فيديو متداول بشكل واسع
لجثه نيره اعطيني اللي بيشوف محمد عادل
ضحيه ومظلوم ونسخه جديده من اشرف اللي
قتلت في المنصوره لكن باسم جديده هذه
المره عندنا اشرف في الشرقيه
لكن طلعت انباء بتقول انه عائلتها هي اللي
قتلتها لرفضها تركبها والزواج من الاخر هي
العروسه اسمها محمد اللي ضربها زوجها وهي
عن الصالون التجميل في يوم فرحها هي رفعت
قضيه على زوجها واستغاطت بالسلطه اماني
الجزار وهي فتاه من المنوفيه في مصر
بيتصدر كل منصات بعد تداول فيديو لمقتلها
على يد شاب رفضت الارتباط فيه قصه مقتل
الطالب المصريه اماني الجزار لسه متصدر
العناوين بعد ما انتحر قاتلها بعد جريمه
بساعات شيماء جمال اللي قتلت على يد زوجها
وتطورات قضيه مقتل الاعلاميه شيماء جمال
كشفت تفاصيل يعني مفجعه بتزيد من الصدمه
باكثر من طريقه واسلام محمد بقتل زميلته
سلمى بهجه الشوات في 20 طعنه بالسكين تاجر
مصري قتل زوجته وتخلص من جثتها في منطقه
صحراويه ورحمه
المهول ضد في العالم العربي الاردني ايمان
رشاد اللي قتلت من كم يوم بست رصاصات داخل
حرم جامعه العلوم التطبيقيه في عمان من
وقتها هرب القاتل لغايه مالاغو امس متخبي
في احد المزارع ولما نحاصروه اطلق النار
على نفسه وانتحرنا اللي قتلها زوجها اللي
رافعه ضده دعوه طلاق بعد ما طعمها 16 مره
هذا غير اليمنيه اللي نطت من حافله هربا
من اغتصاب السائق لها انتصار المختطفه من
فبراير العامل الماضي من وسط العاصمه
صنعاء برفقه زميلاتها بتتعرض للتعذيب
والضرب المبرح عاد عن حلق الحوثي لشعرها
كاملا حتى اصبحت صلعه كل هذه الجرائم سؤال
واحد كذب يعني بيخطر في بالنا ايش بيصير
في العالم